hello everyone I'm pleased to announce
my new tour for
2024 beginning in early February and
running through June Tammy and I an
assortment of special guests are going
to visit 51 cities in the US you can
find out more information about this on
my website
jordanbpeterson.com as well as accessing
all relevant ticketing information I'm
going to use the tour to walk through
some of the ideas I've been working on
my forthcoming book out November 2024 we
who wrestle with God I'm looking forward
to this I'm thrilled to be able to do it
again and I'll be pleased to see all of
you again soon
byebye but you talked about sort of the
concept of a of a a a reciprocity bank
that's that's buil that's what
reputation is yeah yeah that's what rep
that's a good description yeah and and I
think that so so if I go hunting you
know it's it's 10,000 years ago and I go
hunting and I'm successful and I share
with with you well that now now we have
mutual banking system we we have a a
relationship that that transcends across
[Music]
time hello everyone today I have the
opportunity to speak with Mr Derek
Cooper dereck's the Chief Executive
Officer of Q medical which is a private
pharmaceutical company that specializes
in the production of treatments and the
origination of treatments for rare
diseases so um you can understand how
that properly done could be a very
worthwhile Enterprise I've got to know
Derek over the last few years um he
volunteered to be of Aid to my
Enterprise in whatever way might be
useful a while back and after inves
investigating his background a bit uh
both Michaela my daughter and I reached
out to him and we've established a very
productive relationship we work together
on Ralston College in Savannah Georgia
and uh he's a benefactor of that
institution and uh we've gone a number
of adventures together in Greece with
the people from Ralston College the
students and and some of the other
principles and benefactors and that's
been extremely interesting I've i' I've
had a lot of conversations with Derek
about deep biological matters he's an
expert in immunological function and as
he's instructed me about the adaptations
that the immunological system is capable
of we've been able to work out a mapping
of the manner in which the immunological
system works to Stave off
pathogens and the manner in which human
thought and general behavioral
adaptation progresses and that's one of
the things that I wanted to share with
everyone today and I think we did that
quite effectively bringing the
communication patterns of bees along for
the ride it's very interesting you know
to talk to someone whose knowledge is
quite disparate from yours in some
ways where where and and and still where
the communication Still Remains in the
boundaries of mutual
comprehensibility and so I also walked
Derek through his experiences as a
businessman first working for a large
baked Foods Enterprise and then as an
investment banker we we tied that into
our biological discussion as well
talking about how
experience can be mined to lead
to what would you say the facilitation
of broader and broader patterns of
adaptation practically and conceptually
and so that's all on the table in this
discussion so welcome
aboard Derek do you remember where we
met and how I do um it was originally on
Zoom actually I was sitting right here
and uh Michaela introduced us I reached
out to Michaela back when you were
having some health issues um because I
run a pharmaceutical company and and
just have some access to resources and
offered to help however I possibly could
because I've over time um developed a
lot of respect for what it is that
you're you're doing in the world yeah
well you have you have been a tremendous
amount of help and so for everybody
watching and listening I've worked with
Derek since we've
met to a large degree I suppose our most
intensive collaboration has been with
regards to Ralston College in Savannah
and we'll talk about Ralston as we walk
through this interview but dereck's also
been very
helpful in relation to the tour as well
and has provided me with transportation
and so forth when that's been and that's
been extraordinarily helpful and we've
also had a variety of extreme extremely
productive conversations not least in
Greece so I've traveled with Derek to
Greece as part of her collaboration with
Dr Steven Blackwood some of you watching
and listening will be familiar with him
as a consequence of The Exodus seminar
and Dr Black Blackwood is president of
Ralston college and um Derek is one of
its supporters and developers and so
we've traveled to Greece a number of
times and gone to some remarkable places
and had some amazing adventures and also
had the opportunity to get to know each
other at a conversational and personal
level and the conversations have been
extremely enlightening to me partly
because Derek knows a lot
of knows a lot in the biological realm
especially with regard to immunological
function that's something I really hope
to touch on today and we found all sorts
of interesting parallels between how the
immune system works and how cognitive
systems work and part of the reason I
wanted to interview Derek today apart
from the fact that he's an interesting
character on the entrepreneurial side as
well as the cognitive side is because of
what he knows on the biological front I
thought that would be really interesting
to bring to people's attention so let's
start if you don't mind let's start with
your company do you want to describe it
and describe its scale and and exactly
what you do sure yeah so it's a midsize
may maybe large private specialty
biopharmaceutic company we make drugs
for rare diseases so so we focus
primarily on genetic diseases and
therapies for those diseases which
involve understanding the sort of
genetic background for why those
diseases may occur and then once you
sort of capture that
biological um dynamism you you
investigate how you can possibly counter
whatever may may be going wrong so um
the scale of our company we have couple
hundred
employees um primarily in the US
although we do have some European
operations and we sort of run the gamut
from the the manufacturing side we have
inhouse to sales and Commercial
operations as well as um clinical
development Etc so we do fully
integrated biopharmaceutical company so
you told me at one time paradoxically
that there's nothing rare about rare
diseases when you take them in there in
their cumulative sense so maybe you
could explain to everybody what that
means yeah so I think
that a rare disease in the US at least
is defined as a disease that less than
200,000 people have um and typically
rare diseases are are rare e each Silo
each disease is rare because um they
tend to be
fairly impactful to human health and and
can cause real problems and so when
they're when they are more significant
in terms of human health it's they're
less likely to have survived through
evolutionary history so each rare
disease in and of itself is unique but
and and relatively small uh in terms of
the prevalence or the number of people
that that would have the disease but
overall the total people with rare
diseases if you add up all of the
categories of each individual disease is
pretty pretty substantial um and another
thing that's happening just as we as we
evolve in the industry and learn more
about the genetic background of
different diseases what we're learning
is that they have implications for other
diseases so so a rare disease that
impacts COG nitive function for example
we find that that maybe minor mutations
with something like that could have a
broader impact on a dis disease like
dementia for example there there the two
could be related and so then you you
learn about the um disease in in a
broader context by focusing on the on
the sort of hyp severe portion of the
right well well that's that's I suppose
in some ways that's almost a scientific
truism because it turns out that because
everything is ultimately connected if
you investigate anything deeply enough
even something rare you start to find
commonalities between what you're and
and associations between what you're
studying and all sorts of things that
are relevant in the broader world one of
the things you see in the careers of
scientists often is
that you know they start out to some
degree maybe when they're undergraduates
as generalists then they specialize
intensely on a phenomenon that that
might seem trivial because of its of its
particular
specificity genetic mutations and fruit
flies I suppose comes to mind
but as the scientist develops his or her
career and starts to approach the limits
of their cognitive ability the
connections between what they're
studying and everything else start to
become more and more apparent to them
and as their careers progress they
become broader and broader in their
range of knowledge and and I think
that's a this is partly why I think it's
possible for people to follow what
they're interested in and to do that
effectively because if you follow what
you're interested in even if it's a
pinpoint it'll lead you to if you do it
properly and in a disciplined Manner and
striving uphill it'll lead you to
wherever you want to go and I guess this
is partly also what happened to you I
and I'm kind of interested in that on
the autobiographical front because you
started out in Investment Banking you
were in investment banking for 16 years
right so maybe walk us through that and
tell tell everybody how it is that you
your interests transformed across that
period of time and how you ended up
first of all in Investment Banking and
then out of it and then into the company
that you that you now run yeah so so
when I left undergraduate school at at
Washington and Lee I I started in what's
called corporate finance and Investment
Banking which is uh sort of the the
capital raising side we we would help
small and midsize companies uh go public
or raise debt and and uh execute on an
acquisition that kind of thing um and
then I ended up uh moving to a um I
moved to a family-owned business that my
father uh had built after working for a
good-sized Fortune 500 company for for
many years he left in the late 80s and
started his own company
in the baked Foods business of all
things so I I moved into the operations
of a baked Foods business it was a
good-sized company we had 2500 employees
at one point um operations throughout
the
southeast um we then sold that company
about 10 years later so in the late 90s
I worked for that company for a while
and and after we sold it I went to work
for a company in in Nashville Tennessee
actually which was a Mez was called a
mezanine capital
it's basically um helping invest in
small companies so they can they can
grow um at the time it was a lot of fun
it was right in the uh sort of peak of
the internet craze so we were chaos
would be the defining characteristic of
what was happening in the capital
markets at the time and so we're um
making a lot of investments in a lot of
different small companies um and then uh
that company was sold and I I sort of
talked to my family and some friends and
we ended up putting together a a private
uh Equity investment company that
ultimately made an investment in this
pharmaceutical company in 2003 and then
I
just I was on the board initially and
got to know the company and then joined
the company full-time in
2010 as CEO and have been there ever
since so when you started out in the
baked Foods company
what did
you what what did you what did that
teach you what did that teach you about
business and what and so what did it
teach you personally what did it teach
you about business and what did it teach
you that enabled you to make the move to
the investment banking side of things
and then into the pharmaceutical
industry so you because the the reason
I'm asking I suppose is because you have
an intellectual interest that will
explore in relationship to biology but
you also have business knowledge and
interest that enables you to
not only investigate cognitively let's
say and conceptually but to run a
business successfully and profitably and
to manage people while doing that and
that's a you know that's not an
obviously overlapping skill set so I'm
curious to pull out the threads and to
explain you know how both of those
abilities developed so let's go on the
business side first you started with
this baked goods Bak baked Foods company
yeah so I I think I think maybe it is
more of an overlapping skill set because
a a bank Foods company is defined by
sort of a hyperco competitive
environment and it's very much what I
would call a cost driven business and
what what I mean by that is you have to
watch your cost very very carefully
because the margins are thin there's a
lot of competition we basically were
producing a very high volume of like
white bread and the the the basic stuff
that you get on the Shelf in in a
Walmart grocery store white bread and
wheat bread and hot dog and hamburger
buns and distributing them to I mean we
had a facility in BD North Carolina they
would make 50,000 pounds of an hour just
to just to put some perspective on this
so uh because of that fairly low margin
cost- driven business you have to manage
the hierarchy of costs really really
precisely because anything that sort of
grows or gets out of control can can be
in terms of the the cost of the business
so it's
it's sort of the the extreme side of
pencil sharpening um I would say I would
say the pharmaceutical business by ju
toos is almost the complete opposite it
is driven by um a focus on the
intellectual property development around
a unique approach to treating a
particular disease which is highly
complex and uh requires an extraordinary
amount of of thaning to to ju poos the
two and the the consequence of that is
that uh the the margins in the industry
are just just completely different
because the investment comes on
developing the product and the and the
patent portfolio around the product and
that kind of thing as opposed to
managing the cost
explicitly but but your question's a
good one it's not one I've thought about
before because one of the things that we
do somewhat uniquely with our company is
we we manage our costs pretty
rigorously even though we don't
necessarily have to because because it
is a more Pro profitable business than
baked foods for example but what I found
in in doing that is that it it limits
chaos because if you if you sort of are
continuously hyperfocusing on what it is
that is your goal and make sure that you
are um not allowing noise to enter the
situation in pursuit of that goal it it
well it's highly correlated with success
to be to be focused and and not allow
the organization to to become too
chaotic in pursuit of a goal
is yeah so so I'm I'm trying to think of
that from a psychological and a trait
perspective I mean we we know very well
that success in complex Endeavors is
primarily dependent on intelligence but
that personality trait variance also
plays a role and so when you're talking
about very tight cost control I
immediately think of two things and one
is conscientiousness that's the ability
to pay attention that's orderliness and
industri the ability to and willingness
and desire for that matter to pay
attention to details so Details Matter
and I would also suspect a certain
degree of disagreeable disagreeableness
too because when you're talking about
control of costs let's say to me and
this is partly practical experience
speaking that also means the ability to
say no right and control implies no
right right so but then on the product
development side let's say with regards
to the pharmaceutical industry that
seems to be more something associated
with high levels of openness and
creativity interest in intellectual
matters and so that that's a relatively
rare combination extremely high openness
and I know that's characteristic of you
because I've talked to you a lot and
you're unbelievably interested in ideas
but you're also extremely detail
oriented so that's a relatively rare
overlap of traits and so um it sounds to
me like you really did when when you
were working with the in the in the
baked Foods industry did you did you
enjoy
the the detail management that was
associated with keeping the company
functional despite it being
lean no no that was that was not
something that I found interesting it
it's it's necessary and I understood the
value U from a good management
perspective but but uh I do I am a bit
of a chaos Seeker In from from an
openness perspective I do like to
explore new ideas and so an overly
ordered organization is not is not
Optimum for
me as we head toward a presidential
election in November one thing you can
be sure of 2024 will be a tumultuous
year how will your hard-earned savings
fair you already see the impacts of
inflation at the pump in the grocery
store the dollar continues to lose
buying power quicker than wages can
increase so how are you protecting your
savings consider diversifying with gold
from the Birch gold group for decades
gold has been the choice of investors in
C central banks to hedge against
inflation if you have an IRA or 401K
from a previous employer that's just
Gathering dust call Birch gold and they
will help you convert it into an IRA in
Gold you won't pay a penny out of pocket
they will simply convert that 401k into
physical gold which unlike digital
currency can't be tampered with just
text Jordan to 98 9898 and Birch gold
will send you a free info kit on gold
with an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of satisfied
customers in the exclusive gold company
of the daily wire for the past 7 years
you can trust Birch gold 2 text Jordan
to
[Music]
9898917350 conscientious and that you
have a certain degree of emotional
resilience so you're low in neuroticism
those are the best predictors on the
managerial front on the entrepreneurial
front the best predictors are
intelligence once again because that's
Universal across any domain that's
complex but o trait openness and
openness is basically aesthetic
appreciation on the one hand and
interest in ideas and intellectual
exploration on the other and my
empirical investigations into predicting
entrepreneurship showed quite clearly
that the major trait predictor there was
openness by a substantial margin and so
it sounds to me like you when you were
in your baked Foods um Incarnation let's
say that there was plenty of room there
for conscientiousness but not
necessarily as much room as you have now
for the investigation into well into
deep problems the intellectual
investigation is that fair that's fair
that's a very good description okay okay
but it TR but it trained you yeah I I
think that there's a um if you're a very
open person it's good to work on the
discipline you know if if you're if
you're in a role like a CEO ultimately
your responsibility is strategic you you
need to be looking ahead and deciding
where the organ is going and what it is
that you're going to do and and how you
get there and but you have to learn to
constrain your own openness in terms of
seeking those things because if you
don't you will become
the biggest source of Chaos in the
organization because very open people
tend to be well open to lots of
different ideas and so you you if you
can discipline yourself on that front
first then I think that that it
propagates throughout the organization
ultimately and it's it's like anything
you have to draw the boundary between
Chaos and Order yeah yeah intelligently
matter of fact I think you could even
Define competence that way as the sort
of optimum
Dynamic um positioning of the boundy
between Order and Chaos depending on the
circumstances and it does change because
do do you have do you have any idea how
in your present business you make a
decision about so okay so if you're open
Any Given idea has a high probability of
triggering a set of associated ideas and
the more open you are the larger the Gap
is between the ideas that are triggered
so in fact when you're talking to highly
open People they'll jump from one topic
to another and if you're less open you
may not understand that there's any
connection between those ideas at all
now the advantage to that is that you
bring things together that are not
normally conceptualized together and and
also you're a seeker of multiple
Pathways but the disadvantage as as
you're inferring or even pointing out is
that
well if you have 40 if you have 30 open
people working on a project there's
going to be like 900 ideas a day and
some of those might even be great ideas
but the problem is is that well most
great ideas are still going to fail
pursuit of any great idea is
unbelievably timec consuming and costly
and you can't do everything at once and
so how have you learned do you think to
distinguish between the ideas that
attract your interest that are worth
pursuing and the ideas that attract your
interest that are you know that you have
to let fall by the wayside and you know
how have you learned to deal with that
conceptually but also practically right
because you can have people around you
that can help you with that too so how
have you solved that problem given your
openness yeah yeah you know that's a
good question I I hadn't really thought
about it before I I think that what what
occurs is is a process of sort of
aligning the opportunity with with the
relevant sacrifice that you have to um
in the in the investment world we call
it good Capital allocation so so the way
that you do this with Investments is you
sort of create a hierarchy of your
opportunities and whatever is at the top
of the hierarch your very best
opportunity where you can get the best
return you put as much resource into
that opportunity fill that bucket first
before you allow um War Warren Buffett
says this in an extraordinarily uh py
manner he says you know when you're 25
years old down and write down the top 25
goals that you have for your life draw a
line under number five tear the page off
keep the top five and don't ever change
and don't do anything else I mean you
can make you know some changes but but
it's a it's a capturing of this concept
of high focus yeah and so I I think you
have to uh if you have an extraordinary
opportunity you're willing to direct
more sacrifice to that to that
opportunity as you should and so it's a
it's a it's a mathematical it's a math
Mathes balancing of the equation of how
good is the opportunity and how much is
it going to cost to pursue it right
right well so so there's a number
of avenues of exploration that are
gerain to that observation so one is so
if you talk to managers of small and
large companies about what frustrates
them one of the things you find very
rapidly is they're frustrated by the
constant necessity of having to put out
fires so they're so busy dealing with
like Crisis minutia that they never get
a chance to strategize over the long run
or even to sit down and think about what
a reasonable medium to long-term
strategy is and that is not productive
but part of the reason is this is that
the typical manager so the typical
manager first of all fails the empirical
estimates are that 65% of managers add
negative net value to their companies
right so that's a pretty damning that
and that's a pretty damning statistic
yeah I do think that's mostly
chaos well well that's that that's so
what happens to managers very frequently
is that they spend the majority of their
time with their worst employees and so
the perverse management strategy which
is well documented empirically is that
you do the same thing with your
employees that you do with your goals
according to your description which is
you figure out the people who are
Stellar performers and you spend all
your time with them and part of the
reason is is that the payoff as a
consequence of facilitating your Stellar
um employees or Partners let's say is
exponential and not L linear here and so
also the probability that if you're
dealing with problem employees that
you're going to be able to do anything
for them in the medium to long run is
extremely low you don't have the time or
the energy and they may not have the
inclination I mean managers aren't
clinical psychologists and their
employees aren't people who are coming
to them for psychological help so
there's an analogy there know and the
other thing yep yeah yeah I think that
that's
directionally part partially correct I
might say it a little bit different I I
I think that um you you yeah at at a
high level it's it's definitely a par
distribution and you want to you want to
focus your time and energy on the sort
of uber competent people that can get a
lot of things done but you you need to
build a functional organization that has
a lot of different people and a lot of
different roles and and you can't do
that by saying well we're just going to
focus on you know these two or three
Superstars and and and hope everything
else works out you you you have to you
have to understand how the entire
organization functions up and down the
hierarchy and and I would say that that
chaos to me if if things start going
wrong in an in some element of the
organization it it's you know the sort
of hyper manager uh conscientiousness
types that you're describing they want
to just get rid of the chaos they don't
want any change they don't want they
don't want anything to sort of disturb
the organization and I don't I don't
think that's actually exactly right I I
think there's more subtlety to it I
think that when you know and sort of the
sign of chaos to me is that the idea
proliferation just kind of starts to go
crazy you get all these well maybe we
should do this maybe they're competing
ideas they they um the the and that's a
sign of I think in in the business
context a sign of one of two two
different things either you have not
communicated the goal clearly as a
leader or or you don't have the right
goal and and people aren't sure what to
do and and so they're they're actually
doing the right thing in the sense that
if you don't know what to do and what
you are doing isn't working changing is
a good idea now you that doesn't mean
that you necessarily are changing in the
right direction because you may or may
not have access to or be privy to what
is going on and other aspects of the
organization but it's a to me it's a
sign it's a smoke signal of something
that you need to pay attention to and
the other thing that I typically I see
that that causes chaotic behavior is
people have a goal the goal is
relatively clear and they realize
they're not going to be able to make the
goal and so there's sort of a a fear or
threat aspect that that's starting to
occur and they feel like whatever it is
that they're doing isn't working and
they need to make a change in order to
make sure that they're successful so
both in a sense both of those reactions
are correct but you you need to
understand what it is that's motivating
the person to sort of change
direction uh so that you can either help
them get to the goal or make sure that
the goal is clear um and it's
not I it's not necessarily just that
that there's a misalignment of
competence I think
would which was your description I mean
it could be well I well I I guess I I
I'm also
wondering it it it may be the case as
well it's complicated when it comes to
intelligence because intelligent people
tend to perform better wherever they're
put if it's complex but you could
imagine a situation where there's a lot
of different sub games in your corporate
environment and they're all necessary so
maybe there's a distinction let's say
between sales and research so that's a
good distinction the the the great
people on the sales side aren't going to
be the same people who are the great
people on the research side absolutely
so right so there's going to be there's
going to be a distribution of competence
by specialized bin I mean one of the
things we know psychologically about
specialized bins let's say for example
because you might ask yourself well how
do you conceptualize the different what
does it mean for an occupation to be
different from another occupation right
because obviously nurse and Doctor are
similar but probably you know doctor and
and and uh and graphic artists aren't
that similar and so it BS the question
of what constitutes similarity and
interest seems to be relevant in that
regard right are empirical yeah you know
I I think that um your goal is to is to
run an uh any organization but well I'll
focus on a pharmaceutical company if you
want to run it well you absolutely need
to understand people and I think that uh
one of the things that you've been
tremendously helpful to me with is
things like the Big Five personality
profile and understand myself and and I
think if if you can understand what it
is that you're good at and what it is
that you are not good at and there
there's a key component to that which I
I would describe as epistemic humility
you you have to know the boundary of
what you know and what you don't know
and and if you can fill in the gap or if
you if you can understand that and fill
in the Gap properly then you can the
organization will function better
because right right because you're
you're sort of aligning different skill
sets appropriately with what needs to be
done so I think and you know another key
component to this I would say I've
learned from listening to you is that
because different people perceive the
world differently
they there's the com you have to
understand at least somewhat you have to
have some concept of what their
reference for because if you're a highly
ordered um you know conscientious person
then someone who's A Creative Marketing
person you it's almost a different
language in terms of how those people
view the world and so you need to sort
of uh you need to align the way that you
communicate with the recipient of the of
the
communication because um I mean it
literally is almost like a different
language right right well and and you
know we we hear a lot of squawking about
diversity in the culture wars that are
raging but there is relevant
appreciation for diversity and real true
diversity is actually diversity of
temperament because we know there are
five temperaments dimensions of
temperament we know they're normally
distributed and we know that there are
different skills associated with them
and and that those differences are real
so we know for example if you're
extroverted rather than introverted
you're going to be motivated by social
interaction and it's going to energize
you rather than innovating you and it's
highly probable especially if you're
involved in sales this isn't invariable
the case but it's highly likely that
like sales especially sales that involve
a lot of presentations are meeting a lot
of people a lot of group presentations
that's much more suitable for someone
who's extroverted now extroverts can
also be impulsive and and and in extreme
in the extreme you know there's
pathologies associated with every skill
they can also you know that can
degenerate into mania you don't get
anything without a cost but it is
extremely useful to know that people are
actually different you know the people
who are higher neuroticism they're going
to be much more sensitive to threat and
so you can imagine that that would be
one of the things that would stop them
from taking risks and that might be a
very bad thing on the strictly
entrepreneurial side but you might
imagine too that having a few people
around that who serve as canaries in the
coal mine could also be extremely useful
and agreeableness is particularly
interesting in that regard because there
are really pronounced advantages and
disadvantages at the ends of the
distribution so dis agreeable people
they're they're much more likely to
bargain hard for themselves so they're
going to be formidable competitors and
they're going to be super blunt and they
can be blunt enough to to to be
offensive especially if you're agreeable
and neurotic but they'll tell you
exactly what the hell's going on and if
you need a foil for yourself and also
someone who if allied with you can help
you stop you from being taken advantage
of they're unbelievably useful whereas
agreeable people they can be taken
advantage of but they're very good at
facilitating social bonds between people
and making the environment have that
feeling of what what closeness and
intimacy now that's not always
appropriate but sometimes it's
unbelievably useful right and
sole people will tell you what they
really think and and I find that
incredibly helpful because if I'm making
a mistake in leading an organization I
need to understand that it's a mistake
and agreeable people won't tell you that
you're making a mistake because they
they don't like to upset the apple cart
yeah yeah they don't like interpersonal
conflict at all yeah yeah so so you know
we we can see there that one one of the
upsides of viewing the world this way is
that you can understand that people
genuinely differ in their abilities but
there is a very large number of
potential games that people can play and
if you're running something like a
corporation there's plenty of games
within the corporation where you C that
you can if you can identify the players
properly you can put them into a game
that they'll be highly motivated to play
and so you can get the advantage of that
diversity right you can get the
advantage of the diversity you can
maintain your standards of excellence
all that happens though is the
Excellence what you're measuring in
terms of excellence in performance is
going to change and so that would mean
for example that you're not going to
look for the same kind of performance as
you said from Creative Marketing
Director that you might expect from
someone who's assigned to manage and
carefully control
costs absolutely absolutely I mean that
that is um a very good description of
good management right there is is to
align personality and competence with
the job right right well yeah that's a
good definition of that's a good
definition of Merit that's also not
particularly exclusionary now Derek
mentioned for everybody who's watching
and listening Derek mentioned mentioned
this understand myself site and so
understand myself as a site I set up
with Dr Daniel Higgins and Dr Robert
Peele who I've interviewed on this
podcast to help people understand their
personalities and it offers people a
five-dimensional analysis of their
personality and five Dimensions is a lot
by the way um the world has four
dimensions and so personality has five
it's a very complex structure and it
breaks each of the two Dimensions
further down into two aspects so it
gives you 10
different aspects of your personality
and so you can take that and find out
where you sit what your relative
strengths are in relationship to your
temperament and what your relative
weaknesses are and if you take it with
your
partner then you can find out theirs as
well assuming that they allow you access
to it and also you'll get a report that
details out your similarities and
differences with that person because
that's also really useful to know right
I mean if you're talking to someone
someone who's disagreeable and you're
agreeable they are really looking at the
world quite differently than you are and
so if you don't understand that there's
no shortage of opportunities for
misunderstanding and friction and if you
do understand it as you said especially
if you're talking to someone who has a
personality trait that you lack is that
they're going to be able to shed light
on elements of the world that are
somewhat opaque to you exactly I mean I
I think that's one of the problems with
things like like
Twitter the algorithms are driven to
aggregate you into Echo chambers of
people who see the world similarly but
that's not how the world works it we
need good operations people and good
sales and marketing people and good
scientists and those are all different
skill sets and so uh and and they have
to talk across an organization in order
to be able to to function optimally so
you you you can't just stay in your Silo
and just do what you want to do um
without understanding that you know if
the distribution function is not
functioning op optimally then then it's
going to cause disruptions for the sales
team right so um you know the these
things have to align across perspectives
I guess so what did you learn in
addition to what you'd learned in the
baked Foods industry what did you learn
when you moved into Investment Banking
and and how did you learn to I presume I
mean the first thing I guess I would
like to know is exactly what is it that
you did and then what was what was the
utility in that like socially and also
in in terms of your development later
development and work in the Enterprise
that you're pursuing now yeah I I think
uh Investment Banking is is a
highly technical highly conscientious I
mean you you work 100 hours a week I
mean it's it's it's a pretty brutal
environment but you are exposed to a
unbelievable stream of CEOs and CFOs and
you you you're you're only dealing with
people who have been very successful
running businesses and they're looking
to take their business to the next step
and it's it's a pretty um it's an
amazing educational environment because
you you're you're working hard and
you're being exposed to people who are
highly competent and they are they're
looking to take the business to the next
step and so you're you're involved in
that whole process in in terms of
writing a description of the company and
what it is that they do so when you go
market it to U institutional investors
and whatnot you can say look at this
amazing company that's created this new
software or or whatever it is you have
to you have you become the uh the
financial marketing arm of the
organization and so you have to do all
of the analysis on what the how
competent the company is from a and um
an income perspective and and how
sustainable they'll be what their growth
opportunities are so you're you're
hyperex exposed to a lot of very high
level uh financial and operational
Concepts at a very young age it's it's
it and it's it's a very open environment
so you're you work on one deal for three
months and then go right into the next
one and then go right into the next one
so it's right how many companies do you
think how many companies do you think
you
evaluated oh my gosh I don't know I
hundreds I couldn't hundreds hundreds
hundreds uhhuh and how long how many did
you have to evaluate do you think I mean
I know you came from a business
background and when you moved into
Investment Banking but how many
companies do you did you have to
evaluate before you felt that you knew
what you were doing and what is it that
you were looking for I mean so so we
could imagine okay so and I I'd like to
start from basic principles so as as as
Derek pointed out if you run a company
and you want to make it grow at some
point it's possible that you're going to
look for additional funding and so if
you go to an investment banker you're
going to to find people who will invest
in your company and they're you're going
to they're going to take a piece of your
company as a consequence of working with
you and so there's a risk on both sides
the risk to the Investment Bank is that
the company fails or is fraudulent and
the risk to the to the person who's
running the company is that someone else
will end up with more control or more
ownership than might be optimal as far
as they're concerned of the Enterprise
and so that has to be negotiated and so
as an investment banker you're in a
situation where you have to evaluate a
company's probability of success now
that's a very tricky thing because
there's many things other than the
apparent
creative what would you say the apparent
creativity and utility of the product
right there's the management team
there's the timing in the market there's
the marketing team there's there's an
endless number of things that go
together to make a company work and it's
not at all obvious that you can take a
look at a portfolio of stocks and you
can assess the companies and predict
which stocks are going to perform Well
because most money managers actually do
worse than chance what what do you do
you think that it's different in
Investment Banking and and there's
something I else I'd like to introduce
into that so investment bankers look for
they're hoping to this is my
understanding of it they're hoping for
at least something approximately a 10 to
one return on their investment and part
of the reason they're looking for a
return that high is that a number of the
companies that they evaluate that look
good won't succeed and so there'll be
substantive losses did you get to the
point where you felt that you were
credible in your analysis of the growth
potential of companies and if so what
did you learn that enabled you to make
that
determination yes probably not then I I
W I was too young to be able to do what
it is that you're describing I would say
that I've gotten a lot better at it uh
since then and that one of the primary
teachers is science itself and and what
I mean by that is is science teaches you
the discipline if if you pay attention
the data will really help take you to
the right answer and so um I think a lot
of investment banking and sort of
investing earlier stage companies is a
bit of a um would call it Kentucky
windage in the South but it's it's
making guesses as to the competence of
the management team and whether or not
the idea is going to you know explode
and take off yeah what science says is
um get hard data and then make a
decision it's it's much more um cold and
calculating analytical and much less uh
intuitive now I I do think that that
intuition is important to be for being a
good scientist it's it's you can't just
rely on what the spreadsheets tell you
but um
there again there's sort of an Optimum
balance to you you have if the data
tells you something different than what
the your intuition is telling you listen
to
it no matter where you're listening no
matter what job you have the clothes you
wear to work say a lot about you it's
time to take your style to the next
level with mizen and M dress shirts you
don't have to sacrifice comfort for
style their performance fabric dress
shirts feel just as good as they look
mizen and Maine invented the performance
fabric dress shirt 10 years ago go and
they've practically perfected it it's
lightweight breathable moisture wicking
wrinkle resistant and the most
comfortable shirt on the market you can
wear their clothes to work throw them in
a suitcase or keep them by your at home
desk for when you need to look sharp for
an interview whatever you do and
wherever you wear it know that you'll
look and feel amazing so whether you're
attending an important meeting or a
networking event or simply want to
impress your colleagues mizen and Main
has everything you need so what are you
waiting for spruce your style with mizen
and Main go to m and.com and use code
Jordan to get 25% off any purchase of
$130 or more that's M izen
and.com promo code Jordan for 25% off
today well it's It's Tricky too it seems
to me too because I I suspect that one
of the things you're also trying to
figure out and this would be harder to
reduce to data is that when you're
entering into a partnership with someone
that you're going to fund one of the
things that you're also attempting to
specify is whether you can work your
team can work productively with that
team and that's also a matter not so
much of initial analysis but of
continual negotiation as you're getting
to know each other I would presume it is
it is and I'm I'm disagreeable enough to
very strongly prefer running the
business myself so so yeah yeah I I'm um
there's a tangible interaction with the
organization that I think is
tremendously beneficial in terms of sort
of really more clearly understanding
what it is that you're doing and making
sure
that the various functions up and down
the hierarchy of the organization also
understand that so so it's it's hard to
um it's hard to make sure that that
communic communication game is played
effectively and C if you're more removed
at at right at the investment level it's
it's you your your source of information
is well well you you don't you're much
less likely to get the smoke smoke
signal of the chaos somewhere halfway
down the organization that something's
not functioning well if you're kind of
removed from that well I think that's
why so many big Enterprises inevitably
fail yeah you know they get layers and
layers of operation and at some point
the information can't propagate up the
layers without disappearing or becoming
biased in a way that's completely
unproductive like there might be builtin
failure to gigantism in that manner for
for some of the reasons that you just
described is you just don't know what
the hell's going on anymore yeah I think
I think that's part of it I think you
don't know what the hell's going on and
but but I also think a big part of the
reason you don't know what's going on is
because the the the chaos does tend to
become a self-fulfilling propagation
function and so it it as you add more
layers the the midlevel layers add
layers themselves because at some point
the organization what starts to happen
is the number of people that you have
that report to you is finding
characteristic of success so sort of
it's it's not are we achieving the goals
as an organization that we want to
achieve it is how many people do I have
reporting to me and so right and so the
the tendency to sort of build build
Thoms is just inevitable in a in a
large right too well and there's some
evidence you know from the from the
comparative
Anatomy um evolutionary biology end of
psychology that human
beings human being group size tended to
fractionate at about 200 individuals and
so there's you could imagine that if 400
individuals are reporting to you let's
say that you actually can't keep track
of the permutations of their
interactions right and so that's a
recipe for chaos as well know I talked
to Frank Magna who who's run a very
successful organization in Canada and he
had a rule and I can't remember
precisely the rule but his factories
were capped at something like 400
employees he just built another Factory
after he got bigger than that because it
was his experience you know and that
might be somewhat unique to him but I
think the general principle is
reasonable is that once the Enterprise
got to it could become unmanageable in
terms of size and scope and then it
didn't know what it was doing anymore
yeah yeah yeah okay so let's let's turn
to your your current company and so um
the first question I would have for you
is how in the world is it that you've
been able to run AE profitable
Enterprise concentrating on rare
diseases when you know that's an
interesting Niche and the fact that
they're rare should indicate that there
aren't this is the standard excuse as
far as I've been able or Reason as far
as I've been able to determine for the
fact that not that much research effort
is put into the uh into addressing rare
diseases but you have this Niche where
you seem to have managed that and also
to be profitable you know and and people
who are somewhat soured on Capital ISM
listening to this might think well why
does profit matter and the answer to
that is well it's an index that you're
running an efficient organization but
without profit there's no growth
so if you if you're not careful enough
to run your Enterprise profitably it's
not going to thrive I I I think yeah I
think on on the ethical sort of the
implicit ethical question there I think
one of the
um there there's a distinct advantage in
my mind of running an organization that
is profit because it is doing something
that is actually good for people so so
if you develop a drug that actually
really helps people there's a um there's
an ethical exchange that occurs there
there there you know yes it it it is
costly for the patient to or the
insurance company to to buy the product
you're actually doing something that is
is can be transformative in that
patient's life so so it's a pretty
valuable um trade I think
to do something that really um benefits
people lives and and and and can make
dramatic changes in in their health I
mean that's certainly a good thing to be
able to look in the mirror in the
morning and tell your and and realize
that's what you're doing so why do you
why do you think that matters let I'd
like to take that aart I was just
talking to Joo willink yesterday and one
of the things Joo said that he learned
in the military and this became as
somewhat of a surprise to him partly
because he's a pretty rough guy he said
he was quite shocked at how much
pleasure he took implicit pleasure he
took in the mentoring and development of
other people's skills he didn't know
although learned quite rapidly that that
was an innate source of motivation and
pleasure right now the cynics with
regards to capitalism or the cynics with
regards to human beings you know they
they basically make the claim that well
fundamentally people are motivated by
nothing other than power right or maybe
some combination of power and Hedonism
because you need power for some reason
and it's usually to serve some
hedonistic goal so and they would say in
response to you know a claim like the
one you made is that well you've made a
lot of money and you've accured a lot of
power as a consequence of addressing
these rare illnesses and the real reason
you did that was for the power and the
money and the claim that you're making
that you you know can be reasonably um
satisfied when you look yourself in the
mirror or at least not too guilty that's
just a cover story for these other more
fundamental motivations but you claimed
that as a primary motivation and so why
do you why do you believe that even of
yourself you know I mean there's reason
to be cynical about ourselves just like
there is about other people now you did
decide to go into the business of
pursuing cures for rare diseases but
what what is it that led you to believe
that that motivation to help other
people is actually a genuine motivation
rather than a cover story for you know
your own upward striving social Mobility
or something like
that
um well but the the answer for me is
because I know how I view the world but
but um you know I I think that that the
thing that motivates most really
competent successful people that I know
uh
is a job well done a a a
functioning organization there's there's
an element of of sat deep satisfaction
that comes with with well um you know
closing the anop entropic Gap as you
would as you would say and moving
towards a goal that that is um it's
probably dopamine related and has
something to do with
um there's there's a there's a
satisfaction and doing something doing
something well you know I
think we we could look back to ancient
Greece and Patmos and Samos and some of
the islands that we've been on and
that's really where capitalism developed
and it you know if I make olive oil on
my Island and you make wine on your
Island and and we
trade um there's there's an implicit
ethic in that because if I make rancid
olive oil and and this is where the
postmodernist are just completely wrong
they think that that narcissistic you
know self-interest is the sole
motivation but if I make red olive olive
oil you're going to stop trading your
wine with me I'm not going to get any
more of your wine you might get some
vinegar I might get some vinegar that's
exactly what's gonna happen and and and
so you know there there's a and and you
know it it it feeds on itself in terms
of if you elevate your game and you make
better wine
well then there's an implicit call to me
that hey buddy you got to step up your
game because my one I I now get 10
bottles of olive oil for one B bottle of
wine because my Wine's so much better
and so there so I've got to make better
olive oil right and so there's a um
there's an invitation to to Excellence I
think that is an implicit uh as aspect
of of the ethical side of capitalism
that the so that's see the other thing
that that that blinds people's Vision to
some degree is that we use terms that
become abstracted and then then that
carry with them an unfortunate baggage
and capitalism is likely one of those
you know and it's more what you're
pointing to especially the implicit
ethic I think is more simply
conceptualized in relationship to
voluntary exchange you know and I think
if you ask the typical college student
if they're opposed to capitalism they
might be inclined to say yes but if you
ask them whether their capacity to
engage in voluntary exchange should be
restricted they'd say no right and so
you the case you're making was
twofold with regards to implicit
motivation and one is once you specify a
goal there's an in intrinsic pleasure in
moving efficiently towards that goal and
then we might say well you know if the
goal is destruction of other people
there could be implicit motivation in
moving towards that and sometimes that's
true but I would say yeah that's that's
not a goal that's very easy to sustain
in a social Community right and then
that moves us into the second domain
which is if you're in a social Community
you are in a community of exchange and
even if you're not exchanging goods
you're going to be exchanging glances
you're going to be exchanging ideas
you're going to be exchanging well to
the degree that you're interacting with
other people you're exchanging then if
you those other people repeatedly the
exchanges are going to be iterated and
we know like this has been
mathematically modeled I've been reading
Robert axelrod's book on tit fortat um
uh computer competitions we know
perfectly well that there are emergent
ethics there are ethics that emerge out
of iterated exchanges and you're okay so
you imagine that any goal that you have
that's going to be sustaining is going
to have to serve the purposes of
iterated exchange because because
otherwise it's not going to function in
a social environment people will just
punish it out of existence so that sets
a set of constraints on what your goals
are going to be okay so now you have a
set of constrained goals if you pait one
of those goals and start moving towards
it there's going to be pleasure in that
but then you're you've added an
additional layer to that which is well
okay imagine you have goal a and I have
goal B and you produce something and I
produce something and we're going to
exchange our products there's an
implicit ethic that's going to emerge
out of the
repeated exchange as well one of them is
going to be I'm going to try to match
your quality because if I don't you're
gonna find someone else to play with
yeah I I think you you actually touched
on this in in quite an elegant fashion
but I think it was um with seosi when
you when you did a podcast with him and
you guys talked about um I hadn't heard
you mention this before but you talked
about sort of the concept of a of a a a
reciproc
bank that's that's that's what
reputation is yeah yeah that's what rep
that's a good description yeah and and I
think that so so if I go hunting you
know it's it's 10,000 years ago and I go
hunting and I'm successful and I share
with you well then now now we have
mutual banking system we we have a a
relationship that that transcends across
time right because the next time you
hunt you're successful and I'm not
you're going to share with me and I
think that that that's a good
description of of the same thing and the
wine you bet the olive oil so Derek um
I've been writing about um I've been
writing this book we who wrestle with
God as you know and I've been closing it
up I've been writing the Final Chapter
which is a chapter on the gospels and
one of Christ's injunctions I believe
it's in the sermon on on the mount but
it may occur in other places is to store
up treasure in heaven and so I've been
trying to understand ex and not on Earth
where moth can eat it or rust can get at
it or it can be stolen and I've been
trying to understand what that means now
a lot of the ethic that's embedded in
the gospels and in the biblical Corpus
as a whole is an ethic of Eternal view
so the idea is something like so Abraham
for example becomes the father of
Nations because he embodies a set of
paternal attitudes and actions that
propagate best across the longest
conceivable span of time and in the
largest number of situations so you
could imagine this is why the the
selfish idea with regards to propagation
and genetic propagation doesn't make any
sense to me you know because human
beings have this long-term investment
strategy with regards to their kids you
don't just have sex and reproduce that
doesn't work at all in fact if you just
have sex and reproduce your children are
very much likely to die they're going to
be abused they're going to be abandoned
so you have to have sex and then you
have to invest for okay 18 years that's
a long-term strategy but it's not 18
because there's grandparent investment
and there's even great-grandparent
investment then you might say even
there's if you conducted yourself
properly as a father you would embody a
set of sacrificial gestures that would
maximize reproductive Fitness across the
broadest conceptual span of time right
and so that's an implicit ethic now a
fair bit of that has to do with
reciprocity so when Christ says that you
should store up treasure in heaven and
that that's the most effective form of
treasure what he's essentially referring
to at least practically speaking is
something like reputational Integrity so
the idea would be you know a currency
can inflate and collapse and you can
lose everything but if you've stored up
a body of Good Will in a distributed
Community well even if everything around
you falls apart you're going to have
people who are perfectly willing and
eager to come to your Aid
just to fulfill their obligations of
reciprocity that's the hospitality by
the way that's made so much of in the
Old Testament right and so and what this
is I think what human beings really
figured out is that our best investment
is in the minds of others like our and
then you can imagine how that can be
gamed right because if the most
important thing I have is my
representation in the minds of others
then I can use narcissistic manipulation
and maavalan manipulation to game that
reputation and here's another thing that
happens in the gospels that's so bloody
interesting is so Christ's primary
enemies in the gospels are the people
who gain reputation and so he goes after
the Pharisees and the scribes and the
lawyers and he basically says you people
are claiming to act under the ages of
divine inspiration but all you're doing
is falsely elevating your status in the
marketplace right they're you're which
is essentially exactly what he tells
them you know they're and and so they're
gaming the system in order to falsely
obtain reputational points and that's
well there's no difference between that
virtue signaling is there those are the
same thing yeah yeah yeah so so so so
what do you do okay let's go back to
your company what do you do you think do
you think that's effective in terms of
motivating your the people that you're
overseeing and mentoring what do you do
in your company that's effective in
terms of providing them with a Clear
Vision and what do you think the
consequences of that
are
um I I I think that well part of it we
we've touched on you you you have to
understand how communication propagates
differently throughout different
functions within the organization so so
um and but you
know ultimately there's a there's a
hierarchical aspect of good
communication of a goal you you have to
have a clear sort of superordinate goal
for the for the organization this is
what we're going to do and then
translate that goal to individual
process steps and actions for different
functions across the company so so if
our goal is to sell a certain amount of
product well we need salespeople to find
a certain number of new patients in
order to achieve that goal and then we
need to make sure the manufacturing team
understands they have to produce this
product um at this level in order to
achieve that goal and so it's it gets
translated into different uh pertinent
you know functional area pertinent goals
but but all of those are subordinate to
the the overall objective to the company
so a lot of it's just a matter of
Translating that you you do want to
State the high level goal to make sure
everybody understands it but then but
then try to clearly communicate how that
is translated to what it is that you
need for them to do so but people um
really appreciate Clarity of of goal
setting right it um it's comforting from
the standpoint of well you you want to
know what it is that that is going to be
the defining characteristic of success
right right well and a failure for that
matter because then you can avoid
failure yeah yeah people don't don't
want know what that is you know it is um
failure is the no fun part of it but but
you you do have to you have to set a
goal because if you don't set a goal you
you can't accomplish anything because
you don't know what it is that you're
supposed to be doing um I mean it's sort
of a statement of the obvious but but I
think that look goal setting is implicit
in it it's it's wrapped up in who we are
right like you're I think you're
your
identity
is Vision integrated yeah it's
integrated into goal setting which which
is responsibility which is setting that
boundary if if your if your goal is to
become a good lawyer well then you need
to understand the law you have to
execute the law well in terms of your
responsibility to your client like it it
it sets the goal your identity sets the
goal for what it is that you're doing
every day it's your responsibility in
the world if you want to be a good
mother you have to take care of your
children and
so I think without a goal it's you can't
I don't think you can have an identity
Well you certainly can't have Clarity of
emotional fun well I I think I think
that I think that identity properly
understood is visionary and subsidiary
so you need the highest order Vision the
thing at the Pinnacle of the pyramid and
then you have to differentiate down into
actionable yeah into actionable steps
right yeah yeah and and I think that is
what I identity is and in the absence of
visionary identity we default to things
like sexual identity or ethnic Identity
or you know those are all we fractionate
is what is what happened yeah well defin
well we certainly fractionate without a
uniting vision virtually by definition
well the other thing too that happens
with clear goals is and this is so
important in terms of managing chaos is
that if the goal is clear and even the
steps are clear then there's no anxiety
producing ambiguity so you control a
tremendous amount of both entropy and
negative emotion but you also make the
Criterion for movement forward clear and
what that literally produces positive
emotion like as soon as you establish a
goal and you move towards it you feel
positive emotion that's how the system
works well I think one of the one of the
most important aspects of narrowing
focus is that well the the goal you
could you could reconceptualize a goal
as all of the things that you are not
going to do do because because the the
things that you that are going to
distract you from the goal like if if
you yeah right pick a pick an example in
biology if you if you are a lion pride
and you are approaching a herd of zebra
what what the alpha lionist does is she
actually communicates to the entire
Pride which zebra they're going to carve
out and focus on so right so she
communicates the goal to the pr so that
can they can SE they can set a boundary
and separate that zebra from the rest of
them and then the right whole Pride can
pounce on that zebra and it makes makes
the hunt much more effective when you
target your efforts highly highly
specifically I think I think that's what
a hierarchy is it's a it's a procession
from a general to a specific and that's
same thing as a fractal Etc right right
well so so that means what the lion is
communicating in large part is just how
many zebras were not going to chase
today exactly that's exactly it and and
what the zebra and what the zebra is
doing is so the Lion's trying to create
order what the Lion's doing is is rank
ordering the zebras based on you know
who's the slowest and the oldest right
yeah or most easily
identifiable Mo most easy yeah yeah and
um so so she's trying to create order in
in the sort of chaos of the herd of
zebras and what the zebras are actually
doing is prey animals and I do
fundamentally think that a
predator is an order creating hierarchy
seeking um action and that pre what prey
often do not not always but most of the
time they try to disrupt the the Lion's
hierarchy so so they do that with their
go ahead they do that with their
camouflage start running around yeah
they just start running around zigging
and zagging and actually what the what
the camouflage with the black and white
Stripes do is disorient the sensory
perception system of the lion so they
can't actually pick out one one
particular zebra you know birds do the
same thing if you if you come up on a a
cvy of of quail uh raccoon approaches a
cvia quail they just explode in 40
different directions at once which
disorients the Predator right right and
deer do that because they leap randomly
into the area yeah yeah yeah exact
exactly I think I think it's
fundamentally a similar prey Behavior
across almost all aspects of I mean bees
do the same thing when the bear comes
along and tries to steal their honey the
the whole swarm of bees just starts they
create chaos for the bear they they
start stinging him all over the place
right so there's um so so but just just
the the scientist that figured this out
about zebras I I don't remember the the
name but it's it's fascinating uh they
they darted a zebra and they just
painted a red strip I think that was zul
I think that was spolski I think that
was spolski yeah I think so so so so and
and you know he's dead in the day that
the Lions could and what what they did
was they they basically disrupt zebra's
chaos mechanism right okay so this is a
good one of the things I wanted to talk
to you today about was immunological
function and this is actually a pretty
good segue into that because one of the
more fascinating things you T taught me
told about was exactly how the
immunological system targets its prey
why don't we take a segue into that and
this is obviously some one of the
interests that you had on the biological
front that overlapped with your pursuit
of cure for rare diseases but do you
want to walk everybody through a brief
description of how the immunological
system adapts to the the to to a
Target yes um you you actually you you
covered this in in um
I think it was maybe with with Hoffman
but you you called it true enough which
I think is actually a very very good
description so um the there's a there's
a sequence of activities that I would
say seems to be a fairly common um
Behavior pattern within biology
generally and and the immune system
follows this same sequence so it's when
when you're confronted with the
randomness of a pathogen the first thing
you do is is react Randomness because
there there's just no other way to deal
with Randomness other than wander around
randomly and so right you so you throw
everything including the kitchen sink at
it yeah um not not well yeah yes and so
and so what what happens is that and
this is part of the reason you get tired
when you first get sick you've got a
bacterial pathogen that gets into your
bloodstream and it's growing and
proliferating um what what your immune
system does is it's it
creates millions billions of different
plugs would be a good way to think about
it and each of those plugs has a
slightly different structure an analogy
might be um you know an American plug
versus a European plug for plugging in
your computer but but imagine there
billions of them and so the the surface
of a of a bacterium actually is highly
specific it's it's got curves and
valleys and uh you know you get it um
like the island of
Britain has a geography it's a geog
there's a geography aspect of of a
bacteria so what what the immune system
is trying to do is is identify specific
aspects of that geography in order to be
able to identify the bacterial
cells themselves because once it can
identify a particular shape in that
geography then it if that shape is the
same for all of the bacterial cells in
your body then it can identify every
single one of them and so what it's what
it's trying to do is map the bacteria
essentially and and it uses a really
highly sophisticated sequence from the
general to the specific in order to do
that um and it starts with sort of a
general
highlevel um shape recognition um you
described this I think as a as a child
grasping in a ball that doesn't know how
to grasp yet and and so there's right
they use their whole arms they use their
arms they use their whole arms and it's
it's kind they can kind of gr so so the
first thing that happens is the the
whole arm grasp of the bacteria is not
very good but what the body does is it
takes the few antibodies that sort of
grasp generally they get a little bit of
a hold on the bacteria and they they
concretize that first level of analysis
so to how how does the immune system
like how did the cells that get uh like
that initial how how do they communicate
the fact that they've established that
grip there there's there's um so what
what the immune system does is it it it
has a second function it's it's a little
bit technical I won't go into it but
basically there are other cells that
come along and they they analyze
antibodies that are plugged into things
and so this they test and say well is
this antibody plugged into something
that I recognize which would be a human
cell and they say no no no don't don't
bother with that or they look at is this
something that I I'm familiar with or I
know and they say no when when the
answer the t- cell answer is no then
what ends up happening is that antibody
that sort of vaguely grasps the bacteria
it gets copied so the the immune system
stops making all the wild variations and
it starts making more and more of the
first level of antibody that has a
little bit of grasp and then and then
what happens is that that sort of first
level grasp call it from the shoulder to
the Elbow sort of this the childlike
vague grasping at the ball the shoulder
to the Elbow becomes
concretized and then there's variation
this is all called What's called the
chimeric r region but there's variation
from the elbow to the wrist so the the
this part they're millions of copies
made from here to here and then this
part is allowed to be Flex to vary yeah
varying and so as that part
varies what'll happen is some a some
copies of from here to here are better
graspers some angle actually fits the
fractal structure of the bacteria better
and then and you get from here to here
okay so this whole section from your
shoulder to your wrist is fitting better
than just this section yeah then what
happens is that gets copied over and
over and over again and this part is
allowed to flex right right right so
then then then you you get grip like
this and so the grip just proceeds with
a higher and higher level
of of what's called Affinity it's
Precision it's proceeding from the
general specific and it's getting better
and better right right so you could
imagine imagine trying to map a
coastline with blocks and so you could
imagine if your blocks were 10 miles by
10 miles you could push them against the
coast and they obviously wouldn't fit
very well because they're very low
resolution but some blocks would fit
better in some areas of the coast than
others and so then once so maybe it
would be a block or a triangle or a CLE
Circle or something like that and then
you could proliferate once you got the
10 square mile blocks in place you could
proliferate like one one mile by one
mile blocks and then 500 foot by 500
foot blocks and and map the coast very
very
precisely yeah so so what what you're
describing is a fractal Dimension
actually right right and
so I'm going to use a slightly different
analogy and translate that to so imagine
you could you could get on a 200 foot
boat and just Sail around the island of
Britain and I think that's about 3,000
kilom or you could go in and out of
every uh Cove yep and that gets to 6,000
kilometers call it or you could get on a
10 foot rowboat and and go in and out of
every river and and little nook and
cranny or you could use a one foot
measuring stick and measure around every
single Rock and so when you a fractal
Dimension is is a way of measuring it's
a way of mathematically measuring the
complexity in something and so right the
way you can discern this is that as your
measuring stick decreases in size the
total perimeter of the island of Britain
is going to dramatically logarithmically
increase in so you go as you go from a
200 foot yacht to a one foot measuring
stick you go from 3,000 kilometers to
300,000 kilometers right right get
astronomical increase so what the what
the system does is sort of true enough I
think your description is perfect it's
sort of optimum fractal
dimensional uh Goldilocks this it it it
it finds one or two or three different
what are called and so it just Maps one
Cove it Maps part of one Cove and then
once it gets that that Cove is the same
on every imagine there thousands of
Britains all over the Atlantic Ocean and
you map one Cove now your immune system
goes okay I know this and I know this
one Cove and all of these bacterial
cells have this Cove so I know how to
identify all of them I don't need keep I
don't need to keep mapping the whole
entire thing right and so good enough
and good enough in that situation would
be the immune system just has to map
that organism well enough so that it can
stop
it yes yes and that's a kind of
understanding right well this is part of
the reason I got attracted to the New
England pragmatists because they have a
philosophy of knowledge that's very much
akin to this is that how do you know
when something is right it's like well
first of all you have to set a
Target and then it's right if you can
use it to hit the target and that's
actually the definition of what
constitutes right I think it's the right
boundary between Order and Chaos and and
I mean the you you Ed a definition of
truth I think it was with Sam Harris of
uh um evolutionarily advantageous
basically something like that right well
it promotes survival and reproduction
something like that right so so here's
the definition if your immune system
identifies a couple of EP epitopes or
Coes on a bacterial cell and it wipes
out all the bacterial cells it can
identify the bacterial cell it's done
and so and and then the really
interesting thing happens is then that
Library gets encoded in almost like a
language in in what's called a memory B
cell and those are kept in a library and
so the next time that bacterial cell
comes into the body the the sequence of
fractal dimensions of antibodies from
the broad to the more and more specific
that's all maintained so so it it can
identify the bacterial cell at multiple
levels of analysis large Coes and small
small CES right so if there's a mutation
it doesn't have to start from square one
you you can go back to sort of halfway
between the general and the specific and
start at the point where the fractal
Dimension no longer matters okay okay so
there's there's two things that are
relevant there practically speaking I
would say and the first
is if you're negotiating with someone
like your
wife it's useful to to let her let's say
wander around the problem space until
she comes up with a first approximation
of a solution and you don't want to
criticize that to death too badly
because even though it's not a great fit
it's better than the initial State and
then what you're doing as you're
negotiating is you're you're getting a
you're getting a Tighter and Tighter
grip yep yeah yeah I I think I think I I
think that the immune system it is
perhaps a good analogy to hypothesize
about in terms of the way that human
thought yeah it strikes me as highly
probable I think that human thought sort
of proceeds from the general to the
specific so that maybe um you know with
you would know this better than me but
but with a child they sort of learn the
hierarchy of things as as they mature at
a young age so so a blueberry might be
something like food fruit Berry
blueberry oh you know that's
proportionate to word length by the
way the shorter words the shorter words
map on to more fundamental concepts
right and those words have been
conserved in linguistic history that's
fascinating because they call those
primary level or base level words yeah
cat is one by the way wow yeah yeah yeah
same that's the same thing as the
antibody gaining sophistication as it
proceeds sort of down the I I call it
Con centricity but it's really
concentric but with imagine a upside
down traffic cone is really a hierarchy
but you're you're getting more and more
specific as you and more and more
technically sophisticated okay so
imagine this imagine this then then so
the an archetype is like a shoulder it's
like this it's like this from the from
the shoulder to the Elbow it's like it's
a general purpose problem solving
approach and it isn't you have to make
it specific right to match it to the
precise conditions that obtain in
environment but the stories we conserve
the narratives we conserve are those
general purpose problem solving tools
that have the broadest possible
application then you could imagine this
too Derek you could imagine this is that
if you hear a story and it really
strikes you and it's memorable that's
because your memory has evolved to have
a place for that story because that
story is so necessary that without it
you you your functional your
functional your your general
functionality would be massively
impaired and it's like the yeah it's
like the antibody it go you go back to
the gener generality level where it
resonates with whatever it is that
you're I think that's some maybe
something like a heuristic in terms of
problem solving yeah you're you're
looking for a pattern similarity at the
level of analysis that matches the new
problem appropriately you you were sort
of describing this scient earlier you
know when when you describe one when you
when you learn how one genetic disease
works well there's a lot of knowledge
that you learn that translates to
another genetic disease it's not exactly
the same protein but in terms of DNA and
RNA and all of the functional uh
elements that go wrong with the genetic
disease many of them are the same okay
so so so well so imagine that there's a
behavioral space where evolutionary
competition between strategies occurs
and we we've already agreed on the fact
that the strategies that are going to
work consistently across time in a
social organization are going to be
functions of iterated reciprocal
interactions they have to be because
that's what defines a society okay so
now imagine those are all laid out
through behavioral cooperation and
competition okay now imagine you have a
mapping
function and you can map those
strategies that's what a story
is okay now imagine those stories have
levels of generality and specificity
right and so if you told your story it
would be specific to your time and place
and the conditions of your life but it
would also be a variant of a broader
story that people could rely on to
orient themselves in conditions that
were somewhat similar to yours there's a
whole hierarchy of those so I would say
the
deepest the deepest and most General
stories are the we Define them as the
religious stories and translating them
into their specific application is
actually quite a complex act right it's
like you can take a
general a generalistic which would be
coded as a narrative and it might not be
obvious to you how to apply that to the
conditions of your life that's a problem
you have to solve but that doesn't mean
it's not without worth because it's a
good it's a it's a great starting place
it occurs I don't know if this this
analogy is is appropriate but I think
what you're describing is the
changing of the the sort of D Dynamic
moving of the boundary between Order and
Chaos as you proceed down the level of
specificity from the general to the
specific so so so actually what's
happening there is is the it's the same
thing as the antibody is the the the
boundary is moving the boundar is
getting closer and closer to the Target
and and I think yeah definitely
definitely well and in some ways too the
target might also BEC coming clearer and
clearer right because because imagine
that's happening in two ways right
because it's happening you're trying to
minimize the distance between you and
the target but you're also trying to
minimize the ambiguity in relationship
to the Target As you move towards tr get
rid of the noise you're trying to get
yeah the perceptual noise exactly and
that and that is a matter of zeroing in
which is you know basically how we
describe it and and yeah yeah yeah yeah
that that that's how that's how bees
rank order um that's they rank order
flower beds based on the frequency of
bees coming back from flower bed and and
saying this is a flower bed of value
which which they communicate uh in a
pretty sophisticated Manner and so what
they're actually doing is you know they
start in the morning and they they leave
The Hive and they fly around and it's
it's random random they don't know where
the flower beds are and then throughout
the day different bees identify
different flower beds that have more
nectar and less nectar and then they
come back and they communicate that they
found a flower bed and that there's
nectar there and then the hive redirects
the sacrifice to the most valuable
flower bed based on the value the amount
of value in each individual flower bed
so what what ends up happening is you
you create a hierarchy from the general
to the specific it's sort of a parade of
distribution is what it is where you're
you're targeting the the sacrifice more
and more and more algorithmically to the
most to the highest value right okay and
so okay so so let's walk through that so
it's random to begin with because the
bees go in every direction okay now some
bees come back and Report now you I
think you told me that the length of the
dance of the individual be is
proportionate to the store that they're
trying to indicate and so so then the
human equivalent to that would be like
if I watch you put a lot of time and
effort into convincing me of something
it's going to be more convincing because
you are what you're doing is indicating
by your sacrificial action which is your
dumping of time and effort into that
attempt that you're that's your
commitment to the goal and so that's a
pretty valid indication at least of your
estimation of how valuable that goal is
yeah well I mean the dance if you if you
watch the Sugar Plum Fairies the dance
increases in the level of excitement to
to indicate the procession towards value
right so I think I think that's what
you're just is that is that what you're
describing um yeah well you you you want
to think about how well how be bees
would indicate to each other the
reliability of the message and it's got
to be something like the that the the
bee a bee that's willing to risk a lot
of effort in the dance has obviously
found a source of energy yeah yeah well
I I think I think it's actually more
precise than that so so there's sort of
three so this guy frish got the Nobel
Prize for discovering this in like 1973
and um what he discovered three
different elements of how bees encode
the location of value in a language I
mean their dance is is really a sort of
a protol language and what they do is
they they find a flower bed they Gorge
themselves on nectar so they're they're
covered in pollen and nectar so so one
Telltale sign of a valuable flower bed
is that bee actually comes up and he he
throws up in the middle of the of the
hive and so he smell he's just covered
in flower smell and then and then he he
does a dance and there are two aspects
of the dance that actually create a
vector um one is the length of the dance
and it's it's it's extraordinarily
precise so the length of the dance every
second I think represents about a th
meters so one second dance says the
flower bed is a th meters away the
curvature from the so the bee sort of
goes in a straight line and then he
curves back to the start the curvature
of his dance indicates the direction of
the flower bed as an angle off of the
direction of the sun I mean it's
unbelievably sophisticated so the Lees
Hive he looks up at the sun he says okay
this B just told me the flower bed is
45° off the angle of the Sun so go east
you know a thousand
meters and yeah yeah it's unbelievable
so then what I I don't know that this
part is true I'm sort of guessing here
but then I think what probably happens
is that because that flower bed is so
valuable and because there's so much uh
nectar there more and more bees come
back right right and they dance and so
that creates a hierarchy right there
more and more bees that are dancing and
that yeah attract more attention I
wonder if they get more precise in their
specification too as further exploration
occurs probably on I would it's probably
a weighted average of all the bees
coming back and and doing a very similar
dance that that right tells you um where
the flower bed is and so that yeah they
ultimately direct their sacrifice in a
highly intelligent algorithmic way and
the sacrific is their willingness to
expend energy right when when we talk
about sacrifice here the bees burn up
energy fly around so that's the
sacrifice yeah well another thing this
Von frish figured out which this is even
more fascinating is that bees can lie so
so you can have cane bees and abble and
a cane be will come back and do a dance
but not be covered in pollen and and not
have found that valuable of a flower bed
so it's a virtue signaling bee he's a
virtue signaling bee yeah and the other
be will pay less attention if you don't
smell if you don't have sort of Highly
potent flower smells h i wonder did did
Von frish figure out why a bee would
falsify his report I mean obvious the
obvious answer is obvious answer is for
attention you know but it's not easy to
translate that into the B world yeah
yeah I don't know that that we know that
part but narcissist those are narcissist
bees by the way postmodernist bees yeah
yeah they signal for Treasure when none
exists right right well I mean this
tells you a lot right because the the
postmodernist think that there's no
hierarchy it's just all made up and and
we can sort of invent whatever hierarchy
we want to well bees can find Value
right so so so it's so deep in nature
that if bees can do it well human beings
can damn well do it right well and I
would bet my bottom dollar that the
systems that are activated
when a bee watches Another bee dance in
a particularly motivated way or mediated
by dopamine it's highly probable right
because that's well that's conserved so
far down yeah yeah I bet I bet you're
right and and so it's it's going they
definitely they have all kinds of
interesting behaviors I mean when a when
a hornet comes in and starts trying to
take bees they scream they literally
scream Predator uh threat and and so
they they have they have Behavior
patterns that are prey and Predator I
mean going and finding the flower is a
predatory behavior it's it's it's it's
value constructing right when the value
hierarchy yeah when the bear comes the
the that's a predatory threat to the bee
they create chaos right right right
around to to to disrupt the gold seeking
behavior of the predator and so so the
the level ofe actually they sort of
balance level of Chaos and Order
depending the situation so so when a
hornet comes to the nest what they'll
they'll actually do is is a highly
highly almost hyper ordered uh uh dance
they they surround the The Hornet and
all the bees around the Hornet start
beating their wings in in Sous fashion
and they raise the temperature so they
can they can survive at I don't know
like 106 degrees and hornets di at 104
degrees it's the same thing right so
they like a fever it's a fever it's a
wow that's amazing isn't that amazing
right they cook they cook the Wasps e
they cook the WASP they literally
without cooking themselves right so
that's that's right on the border of
chaos and right right right perfect
management right on you know it's like
it's like the peak of a Beethoven
symphony or something it's it's as far
as you can possibly push it and still
maintain order right right okay so let's
let's close this up by by tying some
things together okay so when you moved
from Investment Banking into the pursuit
of cures for rare diseases you talked a
little bit about you know how that had
prepared you to do it you talk a little
bit about your motivation because you're
actually inclined ethically let's say
and and therefore on a motivational
basis to pursue cures that are going to
be of benefit to people how did your
intellectual interests align with your
pursuit in the new company well I'm I'm
fundamentally just a really curious
person so so I love learning new things
and I I I realized uh I had an entropic
Gap in terms of my knowledge and when I
started with the biopharmaceutical
company that's a that's an inadequate
description of what I did not know
actually and so I just went to work I I
read I just started reading I went to
classes I I just did all I could to to
educate myself on every Dynamic of
biology I I possibly could so what do
you think okay so now if I understand
correctly you came across this company
when you were working in the investment
banking realm and then okay and then you
got deep now why do you think you got so
deeply interested in this particular
company like what was the calling there
so one of the things Derek that I've
been working on you can tell me what you
think about this because I think it's an
extra cool idea I think that what's
occurred to me as a consequence of
walking through the biblical IAL stories
is that the yahwa the god that's
presented in the Old Testament is a
dynamic
process that's conscience on the one
hand so that calls you out on your
misbehavior and that's calling on the
other so God is the spirit of conscience
and calling that's a good way of
thinking about it and so calling makes
itself manifest in those things that
grip your interest and conscience makes
itself manifest in it's like the grip of
it's almost like the grip of it's
something like predation because when
you do something
wrong
that behavior that element of yourself
should be eradicated and conscience
tells you what part of you should die
and it tells you what part of you should
die instead of you right and so calling
is like the the be dance in some ways
calling is what indicates to you for
whatever reason where the treasure lies
and cons ience is what tells you when
you're deviating from the path and the
United Spirit that's presented in the
Old Testament looks like the dynamic
interaction of calling and conscience
and and I really like that I mean it
makes sense to me because we can follow
our calling and we should attend to our
conscience and if you're doing something
you're really interested in and your
conscience is clear things are going
pretty nicely for you like that's a good
place to be so okay so you came across
this company and so what was it in that
that called to you do you think I me
initially it was the the dynamic
environment of the academic
challenge that was highly intriguing and
so I I think that was definitely part of
it but you know you you uh to summarize
what you just said you you speak about
Adventure I I think that an adventure
you you don't necessarily have to have
exactly the right calling to to go on an
adventure I I think can be a low
resolution Adventure be a low resolution
Adventure it could yes exactly I think I
think that what ends up happening if you
if you just an adventure is that first
step into chaos like the bee getting up
in the morning and flying around he
doesn't know where the flower bat is the
only way to find it is just just start
down the path and I think that maybe
maybe conscience is the as you proceed
down the path your your accuracy of path
Direction
evolves more more specific yeah I don't
know exactly how that happened well I
think it's this what we've been
discussing it's sort of well you'd learn
more about Pathways that that lead
nowhere yeah it's gaining it's gaining
knowledge about where to set the
boundary between Order and Chaos I think
I think it's something like that because
because you need a you need a little bit
of chaos if you don't have chaos you you
could end up with the wrong goal well
and also if there's no chaos too the
other problem too is that you know you
have to pursue in a go a goal in a
manner that allows you to pursue other
goals when you're done with that goal so
as you're pursuing the goal you want to
be accreting information that allows you
to pursue other goals right so there's a
goal and a meta goal all the time and
the meta goal is going to be something
like increased flexibility in positing
and pursuing future goals you don't ever
want to sacrifice that to the specific
goal you know this is why like a liberal
arts education is such a good thing
because knowledge of multiple
domains in increases the meta knowledge
right right it's it's it's it's
algorithmic or analogic pattern
recognition that that and I think this
has actually been helpful to me in terms
of my lack of Highly specific background
in the pharmaceutical industry I've done
other things that
actually um well they don't constrain me
to the if if you've always done
something this way this is why we do it
because we've always done it this way
and I come in and go go well why because
because over here in this in this
functional area we did it this way and
so you you asked the questions that can
actually I'm I'm a source of chaos I
guess would be hopefully just a right
amount chaos because you wanna you want
to constantly be tilting you towards the
optimum which requires
knowledge it's multi-dimensional it's
multi-dimensional yeah yeah well one of
the things I've noticed about successful
people and this is something that's very
practical for those of you who are
watching and listening is that there's
lots of people who are specialized no
there's a a minority of people who are
specialized in any given area and being
specialized in a given area is very
useful because there's a minority of
people who are specialized and so that
marks you out it gives you something to
trade but then there's a much smaller
number of people who are specialist in
two relatively unrelated domains
simultaneously right so maybe you're one
in a thousand here
and you're one in a, here and assuming
there's some overlap you're one in
500,000 in that in that overlap and then
if you had a third domain of specialty
well there's like one of you yeah so
yeah I think that's that's actually a
real problem world is it what you're
describing in some respects is sort of
what Ian Mel Chris talks about in terms
of Highly highly left brained
specialization such that you're hyper
melinated and con concretized in one
area which doesn't allow for this
Dynam terms of understanding how
multiple functions may interact the
patterns of behavior May interact across
domains right it's a kind of blindness
of specialization yeah yeah and I I
think you can't I can't I think you
cannot be right brain integrated in your
thinking without being multi-dimensional
in your education I I don't right right
so that's a good okay well the well the
other thing that that that sort of
points out too and this is more or less
relevant to Ralston college is that so
you imagine that one of the things that
you're doing with a classical education
is that you're increasing the
dimensionality of
the maybe what so imagine it's sort of
akin to those shoulder to Elbow elements
of the of the immune system so if if you
have a good general education you have a
lot of those yes right and so yeah so
right right then you can see almost
every bacteria and viral protein yeah
right at least you have a starting you
have a starting place you have a
starting place and right and these have
been conserved right the best of the
past is the conservation of these first
pass approximations AR that's archetypal
and biblical stories is what right it's
the first it's the first part of the arm
it sort of gives you a a doorway into
the maze okay so then okay so then
imagine this too it's so so this is this
has something to do with certain degree
of cultural homogeneity so imagine that
there's a hundred of us and we were all
raised on the same
stories okay now these are stories that
are like their first pass approximations
to Solutions but because we all know the
stories they're also first past
approximations so partial solutions that
we would already regard as ethically
viable because we've got the same
initial yeah we've got the same language
that's yeah right that's right right
right yeah you can't you can't you can't
have a functional Society without a
shared language doesn't work you and I
can't communicate if we don't ha have
the same language right well and maybe
what we're talking about here is like
the prototypical elements of a shared
language of value yeah I think I think
it's sort of a language of morality
maybe yeah well I don't know I don't
know if there's a difference between a a
hierarchy of value and a morality I
think those might be the the same thing
yeah I I I I think so too I I think I
think this exists in biological systems
broadly it's more of a micro level than
a Mac than the macro level that you're
describing but I think you know you
could you could
Define like you have to give me a little
bit of leeway here but you could Define
a living system as the ability to
dynamically manage the boundary between
Order and Chaos to direct sacrifice I
think all living things have the ability
to do that they they they all share and
you know there's a good reason for that
because the physical world itself
outside of Nature and living things is
somewhat chaotic right there's even in
at the quantum mechanical level or
quantum physics level we know that
things can be waves or particles they
can randomly become something completely
different so there's a dynamism that's
in the physical world so I think by
definition biology has to be able to
navigate a highly
complex environment that shares the
tension between Order and Chaos yeah
well it it seems like that it seems like
that in the archetypal accounts because
the constituent elements of reality in
the narratives of value are Order and
Chaos and the third element is the
ability to Traverse that border I mean
so in the DST worldview you just see
that absolutely clearly is what's the
world made of well it's made out of
chaos so that's something like entropy
and it's made out of order and that's
something like predictability and then
and and the dynamic interaction between
them what would you say and then it's
the ability to mediate between those two
forces dynamically that constitutes
while you said it constitutes life it
certainly constitutes Consciousness
that's for sure does it constitute life
yes likely it's acted out I mean I mean
it's it's happening at the cellular
level it's happening at bees do this
ants do this they they map they they
create a boundary in Randomness in order
to direct sacrifice
to sensory
perceptive phenotypically relevant value
yeah that's to gargany but but yeah but
you know and and every species is doing
this differently but they're basically
doing the same thing well you look at
look at well look at the look at the
dragon archetype the dragon fight Story
I mean the there that's a map of value
and what it says so and Yung believed
this was the core value in alchemy in
cqu Inventor which was in that what you
most want to find will be found where
you least are inclined to look and
yung's take on that was well you're
weakest at your blindest point and so of
course you have to go into chaos you you
you you can't find Value if you don't
that first step on into chaos it's it's
impossible because by definition the
value is not in it's not maintained
perpetually inside of order it can't it
can't work you have to seek new new
value and right right because the order
is exhaustible yeah otherwise the bear
is going to come and steal all your
honey well you see well you see the same
thing with the bees it's like if they
get locked onto a flower bed that's
great until they take all the resources
and then that whole pattern is now
longer no longer not only no longer
functional it's deadly right right right
right yeah exactly and then they have to
revert to a random search at least to
some
degree yeah so I I think this this
boundary setting
mechanism
um it it enables different species to
direct what it is they're doing it's
it's sort of an intelligent direction of
behavior um that that is phenotypically
specific so so you know a to a bat they
to to a bee God is the flower bed right
so so they are wired to rank order
floweriness is what they're actually
doing to a bat God is a big fat mosquito
at dusk so so they are they they they
fly out of of the cave at DUS and they
they rank order of mosquitoes and they
target their their efforts and their
sacrifice to the Doppler effect the
sound bouncing off of the fattest
mosquito it's a completely different way
of seeing the world right well and for
for human beings God is something like
the pattern of the spirit so we'll say
the pattern of behavior that best
instantiates the most positive posit
possible reputation in the minds of
other people yeah I think yes yes and I
think that that by definition I think
that by definition you touched on this
very nicely earlier it has to transcend
different perspective and different
worldview
so God has to take into account the
variation of agreeableness and the
variation of neuroticism right it's
outside of all that yeah yeah because
you you need neuroticism right because
you you want the Zebra who's hyper
sensitive to the lion that's threatening
right to alert the whole herd to alert
the whole her you need that so yeah so
but but for some reason you know I I
think chaos is fundamentally a prey
response so so the the zebras create
chaos when they sense the predatory lion
approaching them and that for some
reason I have to think about that that's
that's very interesting because that
that also means that the victims should
seow chaos victims should seow chaos
exactly exactly this I I think you know
maybe part of it is is that in higher ed
we are teaching people that they are
victims yeah your sole reference frame
of the world is that you know sort of
this weird dichotomy where you can be
anything and do anything you want to be
totally unconstrained will but but
there's this hyper oppressive
patriarchal hierarchy that uh is going
to keep you from being successful and
you have no you of being successful well
it's going to eat you basically we're
teaching young people that they cannot
be successful and so of course they're
going to have a prey response to being
told you're being prayed upon well
that's very interesting I hadn't thought
about that that that that sewing of
chaos as a prey animal response that's
very interesting yeah off off to Stew on
the hypothesis but yeah yeah yeah stew
on it because I think um you know we're
sort of getting both aspects of it wrong
the the predatory value seeking goal
oriented side of the equation which is
what you say in 12 rules for life go
make something of yourself and become a
better person and um all of the good
things that happen and downstream of
that that is the predatory side of the
equation I think in in in translating
the analogy to Nature and the the prey
side of the equation is a sort of hyper
victimization where and and and we're
teaching young people yeah well that
that first pattern deteriorates into
predator and the second pattern
deteriorates into prey right yeah yeah
exact exactly right and I think that's
probably true I think that's probably
true and and this is partly why the more
radical left-wing end of the
interpretive spectrum is difficult to
get rid of is because that first pattern
of goal seeking can deteriorate into
predator and often does right absolutely
that's that's the sort of in extremist
uh you know narcissistic bully is the
hyper Predator right directionally the
the the far left has the vector correct
I mean those people definitely exist
exist yeah and those tend
yeah but but the categor the ideological
C categorization of every predatory
behavior as narcissistic psychopath is
just well misses the Nuance of the the
olive oil for wine trade that is that
actually does have an ethic built into
it that they just say well that doesn't
exist right all treasure hunting
behavior is not Predator exactly well
well how's the bee going to eat right
right right okay okay well that's a good
place to end Derek that's a good place
to end you know that's a nice that's a
nice summation of what we've been
discussing so for everybody who's
watching and listening I'm going to
continue to talk to Derek for another
half an hour on the daily wi plus side
as I do with all my guests and so if you
want to join us then I'm going to have
to take five minutes and figure out
where I want to take this next but um
it'll probably be a continuation of the
biological analogy because I think it's
I think it's extremely useful so if you
want to join us for that do so to
everybody who's watching and listening
thank you very much for your time and
attention Derek thanks very much for
talking to me today really it yeah well
I'm glad we got to weave in the like the
practicalities of your career into you
know the philosophical and biological
discussions that we've had before that's
exactly what I was hoping to accomplish
and I think we managed that so thank you
very much for that sir and let's take
five and for everybody watching and
listening again thanks for your time and
attention
[Music]